yeah monk Mode's great unless you don't
fill the space with something productive
because something will fill the space
and this vacuum just sucks in the lowest
common denominator or the the path of
least resistance which is usually both
change your friends stop drinking create
some goals what would have had to have
happened in six months time for you to
look back on those six months and
consider them a success ask yourself
that question that's where you need to
start
Hello everybody welcome back to the show
it is a 600 000 subscriber q a episode
as usual I've asked for questions from
YouTube Twitter Instagram and locals and
I'm going to try and get through as many
as I can I have condensed a bunch down a
lot to do with 2023 and goals and
podcasting and whatnot so try to
condense them together as much as I can
as always thank you so much for all of
the support it really does mean the
world to me every time that you share an
episode or comment with something
reasonable and insightful and useful it
really does help so thank you to
everyone out there
let's get into it
Chris Le posden
you said recently that your Spotify
shows that 96 of your audience has
joined you this year 2022 do you know
how many of those 96 are new listeners
and how many are migrating from other
platforms so no I don't but that stat
did surprise me that this is just about
to be year six of the show so it'll be
almost five years that we've done the
show and 96 of listeners found me during
2022
um which blew my mind I I'm not sure I
think that Spotify is starting to
capture more of the audience from other
podcasting uh platforms and also from
YouTube
um I certainly use Spotify for most of
my podcasts now there's some that I
still use on Apple podcasts but most of
my listening happens on Spotify I think
the search function is great I think
that the different variants of speed
you've got in terms of your listening
your playback speed is really great so
yeah I can see Spotify continuing to
accumulate more and more listeners but I
would imagine a lot of it is just new
people that didn't listen to the show
before that
main man Mick after listening to your
podcast I've given up alcohol and gone
back to college 27 got any tips first
off congratulations that's amazing
giving up alcohol will give you the
biggest competitive advantage over
pretty much everybody else that you can
think of uh and going back to college at
27 involves swallowing a lot of Pride
whatever life path you'd gone down
before has now been completely closed
and you're going to be probably one of
the older people in the lectures that
you attend so Props for that that's very
very admirable in terms of tips just
knuckle down you know the bottom line is
that your timeline is a little bit more
condensed because of whatever you've
spent the last sort of eight or nine
years doing and that means that you need
to knuckle down so Focus spend some time
working hard use your maturity to your
advantage because you're going to be
more conscientious you're going to
understand the world better you're going
to have better self-control and
discipline so use that use that and
continue to try and push but I mean
making that call I I think it's safe to
assume that you've got pretty good
things ahead of you if you're prepared
to do that at 27.
Chase 66 what's the last strong opinion
you had changed your mind on birth
control hormonal birth control so Dr
Sarah Hill the episode that I did with
her just took my head off I couldn't
believe how
Wild
unsophisticated scary the changes are to
everything about a woman her entire
psychological profile her mate
preferences are more feminine uh you can
lock in a type of protein folding in the
brain which gives you a predisposition
to be more anxious or depressed
throughout life if you take them during
your formative years which is when most
girls will start taking birth control
during puberty or whatever uh so the
Jonathan height and Greg Luciano thing
about the cuddling of the American mind
and there's this onset of
um increases in anxiety amongst girls
around about the time that social media
was introduced but has anybody accounted
for the base rate of the introduction of
hormonal birth control or the increased
prevalence of use of hormonal birth
control around that time I don't think
that they have it changes uh girls are
on hormonal birth control show an
increased preference for bisexuality
like it it's crazy so I I previously was
super everybody should take it we don't
want unwanted pregnancies teen
pregnancies both bad for the child and
bad for the mother
um and now I I don't know what the
solution is I don't think that there is
a particularly good solution I think
that expecting teenage girls to
understand like safety of ovulatory
cycles and using one of those under the
tongue natural cycle test things to
track on an app I think that's an
pretty unrealistic
uh so to that and it's pretty scary and
I don't think that there is a an easy
answer to it yet
marcuson recommended books I have a list
of 100 that you should go and read and
it is at chriswillex.com books it's 100
of my favorite most interesting and
impactful books that I've ever read and
the summaries about why I like them and
links to go and buy them and they're all
categorized and you should go and read
it right now if you need books this is
the place to go Chris willx.com
books it's completely free
chuo no Carter are you going to micro
dose on mushrooms with Michaela P at
your New Year's bash uh she will be in
Miami I'm currently in the UK however I
took a pretty moderate dose of mushrooms
when I was with Michaela in
Vegas about three weeks ago and watched
Cirque du Soleil live
which was an experience whilst I was
coming up on mushrooms and then ended up
in Omnia nightclub and Zach bought
Andrew Tate's Hustler's University in
the middle of the club because he lost
nods on uh and then we went cold
plunging at five in the morning and
played ping pong for money so I think
I've I've
done my partying and mushrooms for at
least the next couple of months that was
a that was a heavy night
Cloud bloom
does Bruno Mars is gay
sure
Lee ham Chris if you could write a book
what would you write a book about okay
so it looks like 2023 I may start
writing something
um there's two broad directions that I
would go down one would be about the
current state of the mating market and
the challenges that it's facing I think
that there needs to be a full-length
treatment on that which is not uh
manosphere all women are [ __ ] and not
uh sort of soft and cuddly Chicken Soup
for the Soul it needs to blend the
insights from evolutionary psychology
with what's going on in terms of the
data for the modern world with an
Insight around culture and what is
happening with sex and relationships and
intimacy uh from a cultural standpoint
and then it needs to try and be applied
the problem I have and the scary thing
about it is
it's a really massive undertaking like
that's a huge book if if I got that book
right
it could be
a a really important very well selling
cultural moment
but getting it right is such a huge task
it's kind of intimidating frankly and I
keep having conversations with my book
agent about
why it's scary to me and and why I don't
feel like I'm qualified to write it and
then he keeps on telling me shut up like
just try writing it and see what happens
so that is one and the other one would
be a collection of the lessons that I
have learned from the podcast so trying
to really synthesize like the 16 lessons
from 2022 but stretched out many more
lessons uh longer more examples more
narrative more stories and try and
stretch that out into a book format so I
mean if you want to tell me which book
you prefer that would be great maybe
comment below with whether you would
want the one about mating or the one
about lessons first or second because
I'm going to write both I think
eventually it's just a case of which one
do I go for first and any of the
thoughts would be great but yeah I uh I
really can't wait to to try and write I
think it's the mental equivalent of
trying to run an ultra race or something
and I'm gonna enjoy the process of
finding out just how much suffering I
can deal with
noven
did you think you'd get to 600k Subs so
quickly I don't think that we've got
there that quickly actually I mean it's
been five years right so
this bedroom where I am right now is
where the start of the podcast be
actually the start of the podcast was at
my office in uh Jasmine about three four
miles from here
but we've been doing this for five years
me and Dean have always said that we
think the channel is hopelessly
undersubscribed and hopelessly
underplayed and we don't really know why
maybe it just took a little bit of time
for us to pick up a little bit of speed
but I still don't think that where we
should be and maybe every Creator thinks
this right you obviously produce the
channel that you would want to watch but
if I wasn't the person making modern
wisdom I would subscribe the [ __ ] out of
it I think that the guests that are on
are like always interesting and diverse
and yeah it is the show that I would
listen to and I think that we've got way
way more Headroom but it is nice to
finally start to feel like
um we're getting recognition and
uh the market or whatever the audience
is starting to see that this is a
something worth watching and listening
to it does feel very very good
rp8072 does your back ever give you any
trig any troubles anymore any tips so
yes it does I'm actually flying to
Colombia at the start of February to go
and get stem cell treatment intradiscal
injections and
um IV and sleeping in a barometric
chamber and a bunch of other stuff
that's with bio accelerator in Colombia
um if you have a bad back I have two
episodes with Dr Stu McGill who's the
number one back pain specialist on the
planet and he has been a massive help to
me and most of my understanding about
the back and the spine and core
stiffening comes from him so just search
Chris Williamson
Dr Stu Mcgill and you'll see two
episodes the first one especially is
just a beautiful overview of everything
that he thinks
um and if you want to go deeper into
that his book back mechanic is fantastic
he's got three exercises this the McGill
big three and then he focuses a lot on
um offset carries so like single arm
kettlebell carries suitcase carries Etc
they they are a very very good place to
start
Christopher Dunn congrats Dude any hints
on who your special guest is mid-January
yes because today
that this episode goes out
will be one day after I've announced who
it is it's David Goggins
just saying that sentence sounds crazy
David Goggins is the guest that I went
and recorded with in Las Vegas
um I had it planned and lined up for
nearly six months and it took a lot of
work to get there
um the production is
I would maybe say the the most beautiful
podcast that's ever been recorded
call me wrong but I I Adore it
um and I think that
it was just such a great time to speak
to him he was in a good place so was I
the episode flowed fantastically we got
really deep at some point
um yeah it's it's really really lovely
Anna
I I can't wait to get it out I can't
wait to show you guys the conversation
uh he's only doing two podcasts
at all so you did Rogan
um
December 4th 2018 he did Rogan December
6 2022 four years and two days later he
does Rogan again then 10 days later he
did modern wisdom and now he's going
away for another four years so if you
like David Goggins that's all you're
getting I'm afraid for the next four
years you're not getting any more of him
it's gonna be Rogan's episode my episode
and that's it but yeah it's it's
spectacular it's two hours of just
gorgeous insights from one of the
hardest men on the planet so get ready
for that
James Sergeant one what Newcastle uni
accommodation did you go to I was at
Saint Mary's in Venom on Phenom Park
Hall Road Park Hall Drive I think it's
called Uh I put Newcastle down as my
insurance rather than my firm which
means that you get put into the [ __ ]
accommodation so I was placed an
accommodation which is four miles
outside of the center of town and we
needed to get a bus in whenever we
wanted to go to UNI or to go out
drinking and you needed to get a taxi
home I think we walked home a few times
but it's brutal walking four miles in
freezing cold that wasn't fun but yeah
Saint Mary's
I am butchering names yet again I
everybody needs to make better usernames
so that I don't do this every single q a
what are your thoughts on not seeing
other women for some time while building
yourself okay so there is a great blog
post called monk mode by illimitable man
and you should go and check that out he
is a fascinating guy really interesting
dude and um monk mode was pretty
formative for me maybe five four or five
years ago when I first read it Anna
it just helps to remind you that
focusing on
I think there's three eyes isolation
introspection and something else long
story short I think that it's a good
idea
um I think that
there are there is a limited amount of
time that you can invest your money uh
your there is a limited amount of hours
that you can invest your time into and
chasing tail takes up a lot of it
especially as a guy right as a guy you
are inevitably going to be the person
who spends more time messaging more
girls because more of them are going to
say no so you do need to spread the
market more and you need to do the whole
wooing thing and it's ethical and
emotionally can be quite taxing too so I
think
a focused period where you develop
yourself and then re-enter the mating
Market as an upgraded uh more confident
more capable individual with a new skill
set is a very good idea and that blog
post is a good place to start but
otherwise like if you can't be bothered
to read the blog post just commit to
three months where women aren't going to
be a priority to you and focus on
whatever it is that you want to focus on
now make sure that you do not do I'm not
going to speak to girls for three months
and I'm going to smoke weed and play
card like this needs to be in service of
something that you care about it can't
just be
for no reason at all but yes I highly
highly recommend doing that
Harry keenan37 who is someone in the
self-help space you think is overrated
Rhonda Byrne the author of The Secret
yes the author of The Secret Rhonda
burnt
a horse [ __ ] as far as I can see
encourages people to take a passive
low agency low sovereignty
uh
victim mentality when the world doesn't
deliver what it is that they want it
encourages people to like wish it
believe it and have the world make them
achieve it as opposed to it being you
that is the architect the designer the
engineer the driver the fuel of all of
the things that you want to do Rhonda
Byrne needs to get in the [ __ ] sea as
far as I'm concerned
low me's no question just a huge thank
you quality content incredible work
ethic inspiring thank you thank you as
well
Martin classic two million Subs next
year that would be big that would be I
would be surprised I mean this Goggins
episode is going to do a lot of work for
us which would be great but I think if
we could get toward one mil up toward
one mil by the end of next Euro consider
that a massive success given that at the
start of last year we were at 250 and
the year before that we were at 80 or
something so anywhere close to one mil
by the end of this year I know consider
that success
low turton how's the relationship with
alcohol nowadays very good
um better than when I was sober and
better than when I was drinking
beforehand
um the reintroduction of alcohol after a
really really extended period of
sobriety is a little bit of a difficult
one because your tolerance is a way off
and you don't really know how to use it
you don't have a place in your life for
alcohol and I've just found a place in
my life for it now so if I'm flying
um home from Austin for Christmas and
the lady server comes over and says
would you like a glass of champagne
after I sit down in the plane like I'm
gonna say yes I feel like I deserve that
it's been a big year but for the most
part I don't feel the need to drink
there is no pressure to drink
um going sober at the end of your 20s or
at any point after you've learned what
it's like to live a degenerate lifestyle
for a bit
it's such a superpower I can't describe
how big of a change it makes especially
if you're part of a culture that you
know working-class towns in maybe the UK
or the us or Canada or Australia or
whatever but a lot of your culture is is
born out of drinking
um and that's what young people do every
weekend you need to deprogram that and
it is great my relationship with alcohol
now is fantastic I haven't sent it too
hard
I did it once in 2022
um but was drinking whenever I wanted
which wasn't that often and when I did
drink had almost complete control over
how much it was and how I felt the next
day it was great
Joey Duckworth do you think we have a
crisis of masculinity do men lack
purpose how can we change this without
radical leftists calling everything we
do toxic
okay big one
um the term toxic masculinity there is
definitely a big problem there I think
it was originally a term used to
describe prison inmates and quickly was
taken from the fringes of Academia and
used to describe any behavior that a man
does that you find
objectionable or just uncouth basically
so first off
re-framing what toxic masculinity means
would be a good idea and pushing back
against it and highlighting the fact
that this is a stupid term that
shouldn't be used for things that aren't
genuinely toxic
do I think we have a crisis of
masculinity yes I think that there
aren't many firm places for men to stand
at the moment it's very hard to find
a
to find anywhere that you can feel proud
about being as a man that doesn't
quickly get lambasted as some sort of uh
oppressive patriarchal overreach that
you're trying to impose on the rest of
the world and on the other side of that
there isn't so submissive and
um uh agreeable that it doesn't feel
anything close to masculinity you know
courage competence
um doing hard things striving achieving
like protecting providing those are
elements of masculinity that you should
be able to feel proud about but because
of this linguistic game with the toxic
stuff it does mean it's hard to find a
place a way to be able to do those
things without immediately being shouted
at for having done them which is stupid
right it's like being Gaslight out of
your own gender role uh do men lack
purpose
um
I think everybody lacks purpose at the
moment I don't think that women are
having an easy time of it either and
this is like terrible to say if you're a
part of the manuscript which I'm not but
girls aren't having a fantastic time
either like they've got rates of anxiety
through the roof whether that's due to
hormonal birth control social media
whatever it might be 50.1 percent of
women are childless by 30. like they're
not having a fantastic time either so
both men and women like purpose the
difference is that men are are being
accused of being like the architect of
both their own and everybody else's
misery as opposed to I think women do
still get more sympathy on average from
culture at the moment than men do
um how can we change this without
radical leftists call everything we do
toxic it needs to be a pushback there
needs to be
um what I've called like the third wave
manosphere or holistic masculinity
whatever you want to call it we need to
be able to blend together the insights
that genuinely make men feel powerful
and capable and like they it's an
aspirational vision for men to become
whilst also accepting the fact that
there are ways that that can go wrong
and also accepting the fact that men and
women need to work together and be
friends and not be adversaries like a
lot of guys that want positive
masculinity have a very negative view of
femininity like look you don't get it
both ways like you have to be able to
work collaboratively with the other sex
if you're going to expect them to
compliment you so
progressing on from this adversarial men
and women are against each other world
would be great dispensing with toxic
masculinity
repedestalizing stuff like bravery
courage
um protecting providing Etc I think all
of those things would be great and that
can happen through culture as well right
like it's not just small creators like
me
um the more times that a classically
masculine show like Top Gun comes out
and does really well it reinforces the
fact that look like this is actually
what people want they don't want to be
patronized or told that they're pieces
of [ __ ] because they like fast cars and
guns Caleb RG is there a reason behind
the buzz cut you had that beautiful
curly hair so I did so Dean if you can
make a photo of my hair appear from take
me out that would be great this was a
haircut that I had for a long time for
the people are just listening
um it's like a wafero it's a white guy
afro
um and it was very big and it made me
very recognizable on the front door of
nightclubs for a long time for many
years uh and I got to like 25 26 and I
thought
I can't in all good conscience
I can't keep having this haircut because
I look a bit silly and I wanted to grow
up and I wanted to look more mature and
I also want you to look more masculine
it's not massively masculine hairdo and
the buzz cut happened during covid
because it was the only haircut that I
could get legitimately without slowly
growing back into that hairdo so it's
just stuck I might grow my hair back
next year into what I had between the
long hair and this one
um but we'll see
Oh Henry Barr ever had moments where you
wish you could turn off your
evolutionary psychology Obsession yes a
lot one of the problems of learning
evolutionary psychology is that you stop
seeing people as people and you start
seeing them as puppets on the end of the
strings of their evolutionary
programming and
there's a quote that I always use about
the choices between becoming aware of
your mental afflictions or the
discomfort of becoming ruled by them and
the discomfort of becoming aware is much
lower than the discomfort of being ruled
because I hate the idea of anything
having control over me that isn't my own
sovereignty it's the reason that I
stopped alcohol for a thousand days I
stopped caffeine for 500 days I want me
to be the architect the sole Sovereign
controller over everything that I do in
my life I don't want to be controlled
and yet I know that I'm a rider on top
of an elephant right and that I can like
pretend or make believe like I'm
steering this huge big lumbering thing
which is my programming in my biases and
my disposition all of that stuff
um but taking control of what you can
control is really important
problem of learning more about
evolutionary psychology is you realize
how little you have control over and how
much of the things that you thought were
unique idiosyncratic beautiful
cultivated insights or or dispositions
that you do have
turn out to be uh something that's
ingrained it turns out to be something
that you're maybe going to struggle to
get past and yeah
um the only way out is through as far as
I can see with this if you love The
insights from evolutionary psychology
understanding why you are the way you
are which I do
you're going to keep learning more and
more and the solution isn't to kind of
ignore them or forget about them or hide
away from them it's too uh transcend and
include right it's to realize this is a
part of my understanding and I now need
to I need to integrate them into a
holistic view of myself that realizes
that there are limitations that realizes
there are predispositions
but
that actually
um uses that information to make me a
better person not to feel like a
nihilistic apathetic uh human that's
just at the mercy of whatever it is that
his genes decided
Pierre ogis any advice for 27 year old
guy who can't stop partying doing drugs
and sleeping around
that's a tough one
um
it depends whether or not you want to
stop
you you shouldn't stop doing those
things if you don't feel like you want
to right just because I did at pretty
much bang on that age
doesn't mean that you necessarily should
I think that it is a better life I'm sad
that I didn't do it earlier and stop the
degeneracy a little earlier but I also
like I had fun in my 20s it was really
fun and I also have stories and
experiences that have shaped where I'm
at now
hurrying along maturity is something
that you can do
if you are serious about wanting to stop
doing it the plan to do it is pretty
easy right the gateway to most of the
things that you're doing is a
combination of your friends and alcohol
so you need a new friend group or the
friends within your existing friend
group you need to Splinter some of them
off and say why don't we try and focus
on knuckling down for the next however
long the problem is
the temptation to go and drink and party
and do all the rest of it is very high
and if there's two of you
it only takes one sometimes to fall back
into temptation a little bit to drag the
other one along as well so if you are
the most disciplined person in your
friend group and it sounds like you
might be
you're going to be carrying the weight
in part of your sober partner or
whatever you want to call them
you're going to be having to help them
along or conversely you're going to see
them as kind of pulling you back a tiny
little bit
um I would change your friend group uh I
would focus for a period of six months
on not drinking if you don't drink
you're not going to do drugs and sleep
around and party right like alcohol is
the gateway to all of this stuff uh and
set yourself a goal you know I'm going
to write a blog post once a week for
every six months I'm going to gain five
pounds of lean muscle I'm going to lose
three percent body fat I'm going to
accumulate this new skill whatever it
might be those are the things that you
need a reason to not do it I had a
reason to not do it when I stopped
drinking I decided right I'm going to
spend all of this time reading doing
self-development meditating every day I
had a bunch of things that filled that
space so it didn't feel like again
your man from earlier on that was asking
about um going monk mode yeah monk
Mode's great unless you don't fill the
space with something productive because
something will fill the space and this
vacuum just sucks in the lowest common
denominator or the the path of least
resistance which is usually [ __ ]
change your friends stop drinking create
some goals what would have had to have
happened in six months time for you to
look back on those six months and
consider them a success
ask yourself that question that's why
you need to start Lydia Garbutt would
you rather have spaghetti fingers or
lasagna feet
um
it's basically would you rather have
hands or would you rather lose your
hands or lose your feet right because
the spaghetti fingers and the lasagna
feet are mostly useless
probably lasagna feet I feel like I
could survive better with hands and no
feet than with feet but no hands however
I would have concerns about dogs coming
along as I'm Wheeling myself along in a
wheelchair and trying to nibble at my
toes that wouldn't be very fun so I'd
need to find some sort of
spaghetti
functional
encasing shoes like Wellies perhaps like
wellingtons or I could try and get
custom-made Crockery pots
in the shape of shoes that I could sort
of slot my spaghetti toes into
Maybe
Dennis
come on yeah
[ __ ] plan on bringing Sam Harris
um so yeah I'm still a massive fan of
Sam you know for whatever his
transgressions of sacred cows last year
uh
I think he's great he has been a hugely
influential thinker for me
and I would love to speak to him at some
point I'm sure that I will do eventually
um
I do think he probably needs a little
bit of time just to
uh come up with some new stuff like he's
been it's been a little while since he's
put out any original content in terms of
a book even his most recent book was
kind of like a synthesis of
conversations that he'd had on the
podcast so be very interested to see
where he goes next and if it was me I
would love to see him go back into the
um death in the present moment meaning
of life existential stuff that's where I
think Sam is at his best that and
mindfulness so I hope that he goes back
into that
Alex O'Connor has there been a time
where a guest said something and you
thought that's [ __ ] stupid but didn't
want to say it at the time to their face
and there must have been I can't think
of any specific examples at the moment
but there absolutely must have been
um
it's strange man it's strange sitting
down opposite someone and
having a conversation but also knowing
that it's being watched it's it's both a
conversation and a performance and you
try not to be as performative as
possible but you need to be a little bit
performative right because if if it was
just a conversation with you and your
friend over coffee you'd go down
whatever Rabbit Hole you wanted which
wouldn't be a very enjoyable listening
experience so uh I'm sure that there are
a bunch of time I mean you Alex say
stupid things to my face all the time
when we're on FaceTime and uh I I don't
tell you so
perhaps we should record them and then I
can give you some examples
[ __ ] me I'm gonna pronounce this
six yovak Shan sipad Zid Anna 2432
[ __ ] nailed it bro how much do you
think your looks have shaped your life
where would you think you would be if
you were very ugly instead it's a good
question so part of the
like black pill world view I had a
conversation with this guy called wheat
waffles a little while ago
um and one of the criticisms that comes
out of the black pill is anybody that is
an above average looking guy giving
dating advice to normal guys should be
kind of dispensed with because the
experience of the above average looking
guy is not replicable or um usable by
those that aren't
I don't know maybe that's true maybe
it's not but
in terms of pretty privilege and the
halo effect like yeah it gets people
ahead I'd certainly seem to have more
luck in life than I think is fair but
then there's been a bunch of times where
I've felt pretty unlucky like I was
hopelessly alone and isolated throughout
most of my childhood uh like the
literally the most unpopular person in
school for throughout all of school got
to college and still kind of felt quite
displaced got to UNI and even though I
kind of had positioned myself in the
right place at Uni there was still a lot
of discordance that was going on there
throughout most of my 20s you know the
the social stuff I was still trying to
find my feet with how all of that worked
um so it's not like life has been a
breeze however it probably has helped in
some regards it's probably I mean it got
me modeling jobs which gave me practice
on camera which has meant that when I've
come to podcasting it's been easier got
me onto reality TV shows although they
didn't really help anything that I care
about at all apart from giving me some
interesting philosophical insights about
a direction of life that I don't want to
go in
I I don't know where my life would be if
I looked different
um
the podcast is
heavily heavily geared toward audio uh
which is you know a beautiful equalizer
for anybody that doesn't think that they
have a face for doing YouTube and I
don't know whether that would have made
any difference at all the accent and the
work that I've done on speech addiction
and stuff hasn't been influenced At All
by the way that I look
um but I don't know life would probably
suck a bit more I'd get invited to a few
fewer parties and things but
um
you have the opportunity to compensate
if you look differently uh by being
extra funny and it can sometimes play
into I mean like Tim Dylan right he's
not exactly the the most handsome
beautiful man on the planet although I'm
sure that some of his gay guys find him
he Santa he goes through enough twinks
to uh suggest that there is a market for
Tim Dylan but he [ __ ] crushes because
he developed a different part of himself
so uh swings and roundabouts I think
everybody gets different allocations of
points throughout their life and you
should be uh careful about judging where
someone's at now as opposed to where
they were previously
ultan castleley is there any guest in
2023 you would really want to have a
conversation with oh man so many
um I'm really Keen to try and get a
Lander bot on on from the school of life
being in touch with him a little bit
Alan if you're watching if you are
whatever 40 minutes into a q a on this
podcast uh let's let's start moving this
forward I would really love to speak to
him he was him and Sam Harris and
Peterson were like the three the big
three for me in terms of how uh my uh
like emotional education philosophical
education work throughout
my back into my 20s
I'd love to bring Rogan on uh we've been
talking about doing it at some point but
obviously super busy guys so we'll have
to see
um I also have stopped posting as much
my upcoming lists of guests I used to do
all the time I used to just at the
beginning of each month list everybody
that I had coming up because some
podcasters were using my tweet as there
to like front run guests reach out and
basically they didn't need to do their
own guest booking because I just posted
what I'd done my work on which is a bit
of a shame because I think that was cool
to like tell everybody who who it was
that I I had coming up
um I'd love to bring huberman back on
again uh I would like to speak to
Peterson I know that everyone wants me
to talk to Andrew Tate but I think he's
in a Romanian Jail at the moment which
might be difficult also going to see
where where he goes next I'd like to do
a conversation with him that's a little
bit more different so I want to see what
he starts talking about next uh Sam
Harris would be great uh Bill Burr would
be great Tim Dylan would be fantastic
I'd love to speak to Tim Shane Gillis is
definitely up there mark Normand last
year was fantastic to get him on really
appreciated that Derek from more plates
more dates probably bring him back on
again I really enjoyed that one Schultz
round two I that conversation was one of
the most fun
um like two-hour periods that I've had
uh so there's a lot there are absolutely
tons
um
it's probably a couple that I'm
forgetting I feel like there's maybe one
or two that I'm really forgetting from
that list
but yeah I there's some
mindful Mitch [ __ ] marry kill Rogan
Schultz Peterson
oh okay
[ __ ] marry kill Rogan Schultz Peterson
um
I feel like
I feel like uh killing Rogan would be
the the the best
um trophy that I could have like you
know use his Pelt take it like skin him
and use his Pelt as like an entrance mat
into the podcast studio in the future
um
[ __ ] Peterson might as well give him a
good time you know what I mean like a
young buck showing showing Jordan a good
time and I'll marry Schultz seems like
he's a a very nice guy I think he went
took his misses away over Christmas to
some Sandra pay type nice Costa Rica
sort of holiday thing so there we go
kill Rogan [ __ ] Peterson Mary Schultz uh
six words that I never thought I would
say
what's with the Justin Timberline hair
there we are again I dude if you have
curly hair there are two options mostly
right shave it off or grow it long and I
was sick of growing it long
be all right did Andrew human change
anything in your daily life tons I mean
that guy is an absolute monster right uh
sleep supplements I used to sleep
cocktail every night magnesium L3 and
eight uh
uh happy jennin and l-theanine
this sunlight before screen light rule
is just great first thing in the morning
um he really reinforced the importance
of sunlight and I think that's been one
of his biggest contributions in terms of
uh like applying uh his insights to
people
[ __ ] hell so much so much stuff
um also he's he's very
uh
open to having his mind changed and I
really appreciate how he
has strong opinions loosely held as in
he believes the things that he believes
but if he sees countervailing evidence
he's happy to change his mind
um that is like very very rare and I
think that it comes out with having a
non-culture war non-political uh Focus
for a long time especially coming out of
Academia hopefully that would be the
case all academics should be prepared to
change their views if they see evidence
that convinces them otherwise uh yeah
he's the guy's a beast and I take a lot
from him and I'm looking forward to
speaking with him again next year
Tim Cairo how much you recommend
abstaining from alcohol considering your
own experience should have bundled these
together at lots see previous answers
absolutely loads like I I
it will change your life six months of
sobriety will change your life
just in full one is athletic dreams
worth the hype about to give it a go I
highly recommend it it's not just me
right it's Tim Ferriss Joe Rogan Andrew
human like
Dr David Sinclair like these are people
that are either experts within the field
of longevity and health or people that
have tried pretty much every product
Under the Sun I did the same I've been
through every different green string and
this is the best one and you can go to
athleticgreens.com Modern wisdom if you
want to sign up and it's 60 day money
back guarantee and a bunch of other free
stuff but I highly recommend it if
there's one supplement that I was going
to take every day it would be athletic
greens
rp8072 does your back oh got two back
questions in here uh Joanna p l are you
more or less careful with your choice of
the guest the bigger the show gets
that's a good question
um I actually think that you've got a
little bit more leeway as you get bigger
now you're obviously going to be
scrutinized more heavily but you are
more capable of having a difficult
conversation or one way you need to push
back and you've also accumulated more
Goodwill from the audience so I mean
I've stepped outside of whatever world
people want to accuse me of being in
um whether it be
like center right or a cook for [ __ ]
fascists or whatever it is that people
want to accuse me of like people like
Helen Lewis
um Rutger bregman he was the dude that
called out all of the rich people at the
Davos thing like he's really [ __ ]
left Destiny had a bunch of people on
that I'm not
the audience seemed you guys seem to be
very prepared to take at face value and
actually listen to what they had to say
which is [ __ ] brilliant like having a
reasonable audience is
all that I could ask for and I think
that you accumulate that by showing that
you're acting in good faith and by
having conversations consistently that
are reasonable and bringing on a variety
of points of views
um there is an element where if you're
putting this out to a thousand people as
opposed to a million people
there is a a responsibility that you
need to have to not just allow
um crazy views to go unchallenged I
think that's what Rogan realized after
the
um Peter McCullough and whoever the
other guy was lose some of the dude from
that did covety stuff
that's what he realized was that
um balance and pushback is something
that he felt he needed to do so uh yes
to one degree or another I'm careful
with the way that I speak to the guests
but I also think that you've got a
broader access with more skills and also
the audience is more forgiving right
they're prepared to a lot of the time
now I'll get a comment that says
something like uh
uh interesting guests don't agree with
them but really appreciate the point of
view I don't think that you would get
that if you hadn't put in whatever 600
reps of showing that this is the sort of
show that you can expect
uh Jamal maroon who do you believe is
the most underappreciated modern thinker
very difficult question
um one I would love to see more of would
be a land about on he's kind of backed
out of the school of Life stuff I don't
think he's written anything for a while
the last book that he wrote which I
really loved was an emotional education
uh that's a school of Life Book but
that's it was written by him narrated by
him but done under the pseudonym or
whatever of the school of life and I I
get the impression that he is slowly
stepping away from the school of life to
allow that organization to be able to
run on its own
[ __ ] man this cough this chest thing
this chest infection that is going
around the UK is murdering people so if
you are anywhere else don't come to the
UK we have something that's way way
worse than a pandemic
um but yeah a land about on I would like
to see him uh step up a little bit more
maybe he's taking a break maybe he's
doing less stuff I'm not really too sure
but uh he would be someone that I think
could add a massive amount of value not
that he hasn't already not that he isn't
very accomplished but I'd love to see
more from him
Nathan
colossimo this is a long one hey Chris
I'm 16 and I've been watching the show
for one to two years now since the start
of my self-development journey currently
I just can't relate to anyone else
around me because of all of the things I
do Fitness mindfulness Health learning
social media and running my business
I've only had one to three friends that
I feel like talking for most of my life
but I really want to work on social
skills as well so my question would be
how can I find other people like me at
this point of my life should I just
accept that there's not going to be that
many and set my bar Lower I just really
don't like talking to people I find
boring or not on that wavelength this
might be a me problem of perspective
though thanks
[ __ ] that is such a smart question dude
I I was functionally [ __ ] at 16 and
I mean that's a really really high level
question to ask it's a fantastic
position to be in
a few like applicable I could just gush
about the fact that you're a highly
developed 16 year old for a while but
obviously you need something that you
can use uh one solution would be to get
older friends right to hang around with
people that are older than you I don't
mind
um if some 22 year old kid came to me
that was Mindful and well balanced like
I would happily take them under my wing
and like have a chat I've got a bunch of
friends that are younger than me like
tons video guy Dean I think when we
started working together was 22 that
would have been whatever like 30 to 29
or something like that so uh maybe get
older friends who are more aligned with
your like uh expedited maturity
um yeah you are probably going to ex
have to accept that if you want same
aged friends you're an outlier which
means that unless you can find other
outliers it's going to be more difficult
for you to find people to talk to yes
you want to work on social skills but
it's not like you can only work on those
with people that are your age
um
monk mode would be a potentially good
solution one thing I would be slightly
cautious of is that at your age the
formative experience is socially are
super super important because the grind
is always going to be there but if you
allow the social side to atrophy uh and
to fall away that's going to put you at
a real disadvantage that was my issue
right as someone that basically had zero
social skills at the age of 17 or 18. uh
I had a lot of catching up to do and you
don't want to let that fall away so
find all the friends
um but keep doing what you're doing man
like that that foundation will allow you
to be so adaptable and so flexible and
so um quick to progress that I you're
not going to have any problems you're
going to be absolutely fine
Nath cousins have you stopped sold your
involvement in the nightlife events
business yes I have I worked an exit
from that uh this summer finally which
took a little while it's very difficult
to sell a
um
to sell a a club promotion business
because there's no assets the only
assets of the brand right and the brand
is worth a hell of a lot because the
brand is the vehicle for earning the
money and most successful nightlife
events businesses are very cash Rich the
um quick turnover no one is walking into
a nightclub and saying I'll pay you on
60 days or
anything it's a very good vehicle for
generating cash the problem is how the
[ __ ] are you supposed to create any kind
of number of value over that you say oh
it's one year's Revenue it's two years
Revenue it's the most volatile industry
in the world as far as I'm concerned so
no you can't really do that but also
it's not nothing so it took us a long
time to work out what that number was
and then did that and push it off but
Darren my business partner is still
spanking it in the UK I'm actually going
for pizza with him later on today which
is going to be great so uh really really
proud of everything that we did but it
was time to move on
Matt Reynolds are you going to invite
Joe Rogan on your podcast yes I am that
will happen whenever it happens but I I
absolutely can't wait I'm gonna do
something ridiculously special I've
already chosen the location of where
we're going to film it it's going to be
it's gonna look like something out of a
final fantasy end boss
uh fight it's gonna be great
Abigail cross congratulations on the
follow account my question is what has
been your greatest not necessarily
biggest achievement
[ __ ] hell
um
probably learning to be proud of myself
I think
um for a long while I didn't resonate
with the things that I did I didn't feel
like uh I was
worthy of Praise I love or or whatever
uh and I couldn't work out why I didn't
know why I didn't have this same like
existential sense of connection to uh
compliments from people or love or care
from people and I think it's because I
was playing a role right throughout a
lot of my 20s I was this big name on
campus big dick around town like party
boy club promoter
um and that was only a part of my
persona but I'd allowed it to subsume my
entire person and
when I stopped doing that and I
started to tell the truth more and
started to sort of live in a little bit
more alignment I actually started to
connect with what people said uh and how
they felt about me and so on and so
forth so becoming proud of myself uh
giving myself enough of a reason to uh
like feel pride and love
probably that
William Cummings what are your best tips
for someone who wants to start their own
YouTube channel they were about 100
questions to do with this something to
do with podcasting and something to do
with YouTube
best tips
for someone who wants to start their own
YouTube channel um
I would
take video creators 30 days to a better
YouTube channel course it's about 200
books and it'll teach you
a lot of the basics when it comes to
thumbnail design and how to title your
channel and algorithm and stuff like
that you need to understand the physics
of how YouTube works that's really
really important that's something that I
didn't learn up until there's only two
three years ago it was three years ago
when I took that course
and um I was it two years
two years it was two years ago anyway
it's very important you should do it
um be consistent
find a way to produce videos
that isn't incredibly arduous if every
time that you sit down with a blank
piece of paper to write your outline or
script or whatever it is you
it
makes you feel terrified or resentful or
bitter or bored or nihilistic or
procrastinate the process isn't working
well enough you need it to be as
free-flowing as possible Right you need
the creation of videos to be as easy as
you can it's the same reason why I have
one of these here in both there it is
like uh for the people that are
listening it's a remote
ten dollar remote control thing and what
you do is what you do is uh plug lights
into wall sockets press those buttons
and then that turns everything on so in
the Press of four buttons everything
comes on camera comes on lights come on
everything so I've made the
um production part the recording part of
making a podcast as frictionless as
possible everything is always set up you
need to have that same process you need
to have that same structure with your
process right it needs to be as easy as
possible uh be consistent uh learn the
physics of the platform 30 days to a
better YouTube channel from video
creators is a great course
um focus on sound before uh light and
camera and focus on light before camera
you can have an average camera with
great lighting that looks fantastic and
a great camera with average lighting
that looks [ __ ] people are more
concerned about sound than they are
about the way that the video looks
um and just get going like you need to
learn by iterating so just start
producing stuff and see where you end up
Joseph
hey Chris congrats on the new Milestone
nowadays the term woke is used to
describe reactionaries on the political
left the kind you're getting a tizzy if
you don't strictly adhere to the
ever-changing lingo they have for
various minority groups however I feel
that all too often it is used as a
proverbial cudgel Often by those on the
political right against legitimate
activists who are working for a better
tomorrow so my question is this in your
personal opinion what is the difference
between the woke left and those who are
genuinely fighting for issues such as
racial Justice LGBT rights
environmentalism Etc love to hear your
thoughts really great question and very
difficult right
um by using nut picking I.E picking the
most ridiculous examples from one side
as representatives for the entire side
by the people that don't like them uh
you can quite easily sort of smear an
entire movement like calling someone a
leftist now like that that's just a
description of their political leaning
but it's also like a pejorative term
like accusing someone of being a leftist
now
and that's been done primarily because
you do have these sort of blue head
screechy people that are
poor examples if I was somebody that was
from the left I would feel pretty
embarrassed by them
um
what would the solution be
it the entire volume needs to be turned
down on the discourse and you need to
have people from both sides of the fence
wanting to genuinely engage in a
well-meaning discussion the problem is
that the incentives online do not uh
uh it's not conducive for that because
on the internet the most outrageous
outlandish take that is the most pithy
dunk Beatdown that you can come up with
is the one that is going to get the most
traction so the incentives online
encourage people to speak in a way which
disparages the other side in a low
resolution unnuanced insulting manner
that's something that you can't get
around
um
in your personal opinion what is the
difference between the work left
and those who are doing it the
difference would be
are you doing it because you genuinely
care about the
uh plight or the issue that it is that
you're talking about and have you
thoroughly researched it those would be
the people that are well-meaning and
that we should listen to and that should
be given a platform
or are you doing it because it is the
current
uh in Vogue
cultural and political ideology to have
and it is an easy way for you to morally
grandstand and gain status clout and
have performative empathy that puts you
on a pedestal if you're doing it for
those reasons [ __ ] off into the sea that
is the difference between the two one
person is doing it because they
genuinely care about the
issues at hand and the other person is
doing it because they see an easy route
to accumulate status whilst having to do
nothing difficult to accumulate it
that's the difference between the two
how you fix it
that's a more difficult question
car fallock congratulations Chris my
question is where the term Bro Science
originated from it's a phrase that's
made its way into my vocabulary from
your podcast and as curious as to its
Origins uh Dom Mazzetti who is a
YouTuber that does pretty sure his
channel is like cold bro science or
something uh but yeah he that was the
first person that I learned it from it's
just anything that is
unsubstantiated inclinations that you
think this might be right this sounds
about right it seems right to me uh and
it is a very nice way you know the I
spoke to Schultz about that thing where
comedians have got the
get out of jail free card they can press
a light that goes on over their heads
and you're like oh I was just telling a
joke it doesn't matter you don't need to
accuse me of being a bigot this is the
same but for psychology and philosophy
insights I can just say oh so here's
something that I've just bro signed I.E
don't take the next 30 seconds or 60
seconds seriously I'm pulling this out
of my ass I hope that it goes well
is it a little bit of a uh
like a low ball
um way too
make yourself not culpable for the
things that you're talking about
maybe but it works
green and blue what's your advice for
being surrounded by negative people from
work to home life and from the
negativity that seems to have taken over
online without becoming a recluse It
seems impossible to escape
find positive people man Mike you can
offset an entire world of negativity
with a few positive people this is
something that I learned since being in
America the American disposition is way
more positive than pretty much anywhere
else sometimes it can be annoying right
but my housemate Zach is a really good
counterbalance to me I am this sort of
slightly more dour slightly more chill
peaceful guy and he is this massive
excitable Alsatian and he pulls me out
of my positivity and I out of my
whatever negativity and I provide order
to what it is that he does so I've got
you know a group of friends in Austin
that are fantastic counterbalances and
there's maybe like let's say there's
five of them that I focus on and all of
them are able to outweigh the internet
so just find a small group of people and
rely on them
Sierra 619 congratulations Chris you
deserve it one of the best podcasts I
have listened to thank you I love that
you have a large amount of topics and
different people come on keep up the
amazing work thank you very much Q it
would be interesting to me to start a
podcast however I don't have a YouTube
channel or an Instagram that I post
frequently on I haven't made a name for
myself when you started your podcast was
it hard to find people that would take
that time to talk to you especially
someone like Jocko or Jordan Peterson
that are extremely busy they probably
have plenty of people that would take
that would like their time do you have
to make a name for yourself in some of
the way before you can have a podcast
absolutely not
every person that thinks that love
island or take me out or being a club
promoter gave me any kind of platform
for beginning this podcast could not be
more wrong I came out with love island
with I think 7 000 more followers on
Instagram than when I went in and the
show was so tiny in season one which is
why I'm not quite easy for me to
dispense with that label because nobody
knew that I'd done it basically that
most people find out about me doing love
Island from me telling them about it on
the podcast as opposed to it being some
springboard that created the career
um the way that I got a lot of guests on
the show uh you know episode three and
four I think with Dave Castro the
director of the CrossFit Games and Dan
Bailey uh CrossFit OG
um James Clear was within the first 30
episodes I think Robert Greene was
within the first 40 episodes I just
reached out to people people are very
responsive if you are uh respectful of
their time and kind and it just seems to
work do not be afraid of reaching out to
people and dming them or sending emails
uh they are very very responsive to it
when you're talking about the jockos and
the Petersons of the world yeah like
you're going to need an in you need a
warm lead they're not going to speak to
you for the most part unless you do get
a referral from one place or another
um
that is
more challenging but that's just
networking right like you are probably
only three degrees of separation from
Joker willink in any case so okay I'll
continue to expand the net until I get
to the stage where I've got level one
then level two and then level three and
then you got him
Noah Wilson you damn Legend you how are
you now this morning what I'm asking is
I guess are you still hungry you've come
a long way pretty much from near bottom
to top in just to top just one year will
we see the Takeover of Chris Williamson
next year or are we taking another year
to execute our goals with Precision to
add tools to the Rolodex can't wait to
see where we will go
I think 2023 is going to be a year that
I really put my foot down like my plan
is to fist [ __ ] 2023 I would be
I think this is the year where all of
the preparation that I've done up until
this point starts to really get put on a
pedestal and
yeah I
I wouldn't bet against me this year
unless I put my foot in my mouth uh and
have some huge error which is always a
possibility but yeah I'm really gonna
try and make some big waves this year uh
uh it's interesting that you talk about
is a another year to add tools to the
Rolodex
because that is something that I saw for
a very long time you know sat right
there next to where I'm recording on
this little seat with this blanket on my
lap meditating or journaling or reading
or or doing [ __ ] introspective work
or whatever it was that I was doing
right
that is a price that you need to pay in
order to be able to be ready to take
advantage of whatever platform comes
down the line
um you know going on Rogan was
phenomenal but I'm very very glad that
I'd accumulated 500 episodes before I
had the chance to go on if I'd done that
at 150 I wouldn't have been ready if I'd
done that at 400 I would have been less
ready so
all of the work that you get to put in
to accumulate the skills that you need
means that when the opportunity finally
comes you can take advantage of it
that's the way that you should see it
all of the time that you're sat spinning
your wheels wishing that you had better
opportunities in front of you you can
take that as I'm going to be more ready
when that opportunity finally does rear
its head and that's how I've seen it but
I think I'm done with the accumulating
of skills bet for a little while and
it's now time to step out onto the
stadium floor
double do you want to get married and
have children anytime soon how many
children I can't wait to be a dad can't
wait to get married
do I want to have them anytime soon I'm
not sure uh how many children
I think two to three I'm an only child
right so for me
one is a it's I think it's sub-optimal
but it's not a ridiculous amount of
children to have however I do think that
on average
I would like I think three ideally two
boys and a girl in the order that my
business partner Darren had which was
boy boy girl I feel like that's a a good
way to do things however for every boy
that you have it does increase the
chances of your son being get so I could
have I could have a straight I could
have a gay and I could have a girl like
the big three
uh do you want to no that's the same one
Harrington ja how do you continue to
find new content and interests bro
there I have more things that I want to
learn about than
10 lifetimes would give me enough room
to to delve into
there is an endless amount of stuff that
I'm interested in so
I don't know I uh
I just I I really want to
keep on finding the most interesting
people who right now no one knows about
and the world needs to and continue to
put them at the Forefront of this ever
growing platform like that would make me
very happy
I find it on Twitter on Instagram I find
it in books I find it in other podcasts
that I listen to I find it in blog posts
I've been a massive fan of uh
sub stack this year I've started
subscribing not to tons but to some
really good ones some of the good ones I
subscribe to Rob Henderson gwynda Bogle
Eric Hull uh pirate wires by Mike Solana
uh Adam mastroini's uh experimental
history
astral codex 10
those are the main ones that come to
mind and the browser as well that's not
sub stack technically
um
those are that's been where I've got a
lot of new content insights uh but the
vehicle for that is just
ass shaking curiosity like just a
reality Distortion field of curiosity
Josh do you Mal thoughts on why all
these random dating shows are so popular
uh yeah I mean what is it love is blind
uh
um
there was one that was to do with dating
if you were twins uh that my friends
Henry and will were on love Island The
Bachelor The Bachelor in Paradise
uh too hot to handle as well that's just
in its second season
the reason that I think they're so
popular is because
fundamentally people understand that
finding a partner is an important part
of your life and
people want to observe the process of
that occurring like it is one of the
fundamental gossip generators that human
tribes would have had for a long time
who is dating who who is changing in
terms of status and um accolades within
a group a small group right it's never a
dating show with 500 people on it it's
always a dating show that's very very
small if you were to take a Dunbar
number group of 150 humans the number
that are between the ages of 18 and 35
would probably be about 10 to 12 that
would be available maybe uh
that's now just who is the available
dating group will take everybody else
will take the kids and the parents and
grandparents out of the way and the ones
that are already mated off and will
throw the the remaining group into an
island or a villa or something and we'll
let them battle it out and then we'll
discuss Who is the
bastard or the cool one amongst them
that's why I think it's compelling it's
also compelling because
it is chicken soup for distraction and
it generates a [ __ ] ton of content it
makes people very tribal you know like
I'm an Adam Collard person or I'm a like
whatever
you pin your colors to the flag of
whichever person it is that you're
watching
uh Victor J when are you having Matthew
Walker on the show so Matthew Walker is
a guy that wrote why we sleep and number
I think it's number 1109 uh his episode
on Rogan
was one of the most important podcasts
that I ever listened to I had completely
degraded my sleep mostly throughout my
20s from being a club promoter however I
have heard a lot of criticisms about
Matthew Walker's book and I don't know
why uh I I haven't done enough digging
but
he has been in a bit of bother and
I would probably need to do some
research before because there's a lot of
criticisms floating around that being
said his lesson of focus on sleep is
very important uh before I would bring
him on I would want to probably do a bit
of scrutiny on those criticisms and
maybe if that was the case that would be
a good angle to
have him on the show to talk about to
get him to address some of those uh
because I don't think I've heard him do
that
Tim D Simons did you find Jocko
difficult to deal with it sounded like
he was giving very little
yeah so uh I don't think he tweeted
about it about a month afterward or a
couple of months afterwards someone had
mentioned you seemed a little bit off on
the podcast with Chris was there a
problem uh and I think he said he hadn't
trained that morning which he'd put him
in a mood
uh uh he was fine I mean if you want to
go and listen to his episode with
Michaela or his episode with Lex both of
which I listen to in preparation for the
episode I did with him
mine was like
hug mine was mine was a warm cuddle
throughout most of it so there are
gradations to what a whatever 30-year
veteran Navy Seals
um Frosty disposition can get to and he
was it was fun like and also a really
important learning experience for me to
have this big production to fly all the
way out to San Diego to sit down with
this guy that I knew you know hundreds
of thousands millions of people were
going to watch these episodes in these
clips and it was really important for me
to feel that pressure of [ __ ] like this
isn't going to be just an easy walk in
the park where I can poke him with a
short question and then see a huge antic
fall out of him so that was really
important I took it as a very valuable
like Strategic Learning opportunity and
we got him well like I'd love to have
him back on I think I will but uh yeah
maybe make sure that he trains before we
record next time
quiet Tech 25 favorite evolutionary
biology books I'm going to give you
evolutionary psychology just because
evolutionary biology isn't really my
area of expertise uh I would say the
moral Animal by Robert Wright again
Chris willlex.com books all of these
will be in there go and get it free
reading list blah blah uh moral Animal
by Robert Wright the ape who understood
the universe by Steve Stuart Williams is
the number one primer the in fact just
the ape who understood the universe by
Steve Stuart Williams all you need is
that book and then from that you can
tumble into David buss's Men Behaving
Badly uh or David buses the evolution of
Desire Jeffrey Miller The Mating mind
um but start off with Steve's book
that's great uh a a p Vox is it safe to
work out Commando
depends how big your dong is I suppose
rattlesnake.tv has it been difficult to
cater your message around YouTube
censorship
uh
not really
um I we've got popped we got popped for
a conversation I had with Schultz one of
the clips got diddled
um and maybe one or two others but
generally my relationship with YouTube
so far has been great my partner manager
there is also fantastic catcher uh and
if there's ever any problems I can
usually speak to her I think
the rules on YouTube are a lot more
tight than some people would like
but for me my like Overton window of
what I typically want to talk about
doesn't at least on a podcast not
necessarily in private doesn't stray too
far outside of that so I don't feel like
I need to be too constrained
stem my strello why is the background
split in red and blue lights uh not sure
what you mean uh if it's this if it's
the fact that I've got teal and copper
here it's because it is a color palette
that I absolutely adore I really like
that it's sort of Classic Hollywood look
it's kind of adastra E
space travel meets sort of old and
worldly filament bulb [ __ ] uh I just
like it I thought it was cool uh Smith
am but what is your number one life hack
and why speed up your trackpad put your
trackpad speed to as fast as it goes and
your mouse will move around the screen
more quickly like
thank me later
Joe S hey Chris what is the single best
advice you have heard for guys in their
20s
work hard like learn how hard you can
work actually
um push yourself to the Limit the
absolute limit of how hard you can work
because that is going to set a tone of
what you can expect from yourself later
in life learn to love work learn to love
working learn to love working hard learn
to appreciate sacrificing now for
rewards in the future
Joseph Tucker how do you think YouTubers
will adapt their style in 2023 are you
planning to do anything differently
um this short form stuff seems to be a
big part of it like people are really
pushing hard for YouTube shorts
um
I don't think the audiograms are going
to take off I don't think you're going
to see those like audio clips where
there's no video associated with them
and it's a waveform with captions just
don't think that they're able to compete
with video clips so all of these sort of
clippable audio Services I I don't think
that it's there when you when almost all
podcasts are available in video audio
isn't going to take over in Clips
um
in terms of adapting stuff we're just
going to keep on doing what we do I the
conversations that I have the quality of
them in terms of the guests that come on
the room that they have to breathe the
reasonableness and the insightfulness of
the audience you guys and
keep on doing those big Productions like
what you're going to see from the
Goggins episode which again I
like if I could get four or five of
those a year out
I don't need to do anything else I can
keep taking over with the normal
episodes and those will be the flagship
super eye catchy uh growth engine bits
it'll be perfect
incredible Matt hey Chris love your work
you talk a lot about the manosphere and
the issues that they address heavily in
their content with your guests do you
plan plan on having a conversation
directly with a few of those guys and
girls in that space anytime soon it
depends on what you mean by manosphere
it depends on whether you mean uh David
Buss and Jeffrey Miller who are the guys
that did the studies that the guys in
the manosphere
misquote or turn into their own like I
much prefer going to the actual Source
if I'm going to talk about hormonal
birth control I don't want to do it with
some guy that once was like part of a
men's rights Reddit thread and wants to
say about how hormonal birth control is
allowing all women to be [ __ ] I'd
rather speak to Dr Sarah Hill who is the
woman that did the work
the manosphere at the moment needs like
I don't know it needs sanitizing it
needs to be more collaborative it needs
to be more mindful it needs to be more
holistic it needs to be more positive it
is a [ __ ] negative space to be in and
it needs to not see women as adversaries
like I don't consider myself a part of
the manosphere I don't consider myself a
part of red pill
I'll keep on speaking to the people that
do the research
and having great conversations with them
about their insights
maybe at some point in the future but I
I know I don't feel like I have a
massive amount to gain from that just
yet we'll see
um boyo Terry hi Chris how have you
managed to avoid any drama I have
thought about doing something in the
public Arena of social media it looks
funny gives me a chance to flex my
social and creative muscles but I was a
bit of a lad in my younger years I'm
nervous my past will come back to haunt
me how have you managed to avoid this
any tips I don't know I don't know why
uh drama hasn't come uh chasing me down
I make a point of not calling people out
except for Brian Rose from londonreal in
fact no I just make a point of not
calling out people that aren't egregious
[ __ ] if you're a complete dick fine
you're up for debate with me but
as far as I'm concerned I would much
sooner have a positive conversation
about something that's interesting as
opposed to try and kick off beef I think
you don't really have much to worry
about
the likelihood of you getting to the
size where something from your past
would come up to then destroy your
current what you have built is
relatively small and if you do get to
that stage and you're being honest and
truthful and you integrate that previous
lad version of yourself into who you are
now you're basically uncancelable and
that's hopefully the situation I'll get
myself towards as well
uh
Malcolm J hey Chris thank you for all
the work you've done this year your
podcasts have been super insightful and
eye-opening I've been wondering whether
you would ever do some kind of collab
with Lex Friedman cheers and happy
holidays from Miami
thank you very much uh yeah Lex is a
busy guy but me and him spent not
Thanksgiving just gone but the one
before that together gone super well
um yeah I would like to do some work
with him maybe 2023 will be the year
we're both in Austin together but the
guy's busy he's building robots and
trying to save the world so you know
it'll happen when it happens
Raymond tandal do you meditate if yes
I'm curious to know how it has impacted
your well-being yes I have I've probably
done between a thousand and 1500
sessions over the last six years
something like that so not massive
compliance average length of probably
between 10 and 15 minutes about half of
that has been guided through a
combination of headspace and waking up
uh and
um
[ __ ] what's Corey Allen's thing whatever
Corey Allen's meditation program is and
the other half has been unguided
it massively impacts my well-being it
makes me more
calm it creates a mindfulness Gap in
between stimulus and response it gives
me better insight into my own thoughts I
mean it it's phenomenal it's it's been
one of the big changes that I made
uh vendant Patel from where do you buy
your t-shirts Chris
I'm gonna guess that you mean the ones
that I wear mostly on the big episodes
because I get asked about those a lot
and there's Zara uh I think I'm an XL in
Zara because they're made for teeny tiny
little European men uh but
those are
pretty great quality like smart work
perfectly well great quality cotton and
they last for a good while other stuff a
lot of gymshark obviously
um pretty much all of my wardrobe now is
gymshark and Zara that's it
congrats I listened to your podcast
every week question where should women
seek advice to become better mothers
so I literally don't have an answer to
that
I don't know
which is pretty damning
if you have any suggestions for where
women can find advice about how to
become better mothers please put it in
the comments
Joey Starr what's your advice for a
young man in his early 20s not wanting
to feel the promiscuity train but rather
find a good quality woman to settle down
with and have a family they're out there
man there are girls that are ready to
settle down oh there's more this is a
predicament many young man are facing
not all of us want to submit to the
degeneracy and savagery of the dating
market for many of us following the
traditional virtuous route is more more
appealing however finding a woman who
hasn't been dragged through the
promiscuity phase is difficult but
you're 20 they probably haven't had
chance to get through it so go on as
many dates as you can as quickly as you
can
and find the one that's right and make a
life with them my business partner and
his misses I think started dating when
they were 19. they're now 34 34 and 35
three kids two dogs white picket fence
perfect life like get started and
behave in the same manner that you would
want the partner that you're trying to
find to behave in so don't go out on
dates and try and [ __ ] them on the first
night like spend time make them aware
that this is something serious not
something that you're looking for that's
transactional
uh Harry lease what is your favorite UK
City Edinburgh by far it's like real
world Harry Potter land
con McCloskey are you on trt
no
never been on trt would consider it
would like to be on it but no
Nick class what is your opinion on
Andrew Tate being unmanned on Instagram
fine like I don't mind too much really
uh I don't know what you did to get
banned in the first place and his
Instagram is kind of funny
Gavin what's the simplest and most
effective way to trim your pubes going
into 2023
I would say manscaped lawnmower 4.0
that's the way that I do it seems
pretty useful to me
um
triggered Londa what do you think about
wef and Jews
that's going to be a difficult question
to answer without getting canceled is it
well actually no it's not I just don't
have any thoughts on it like what do you
mean
what do you think about wef and Jews
I they share a lot of letters in the
name I don't know I haven't done my
research on that stuff
Ted Wonderlic
do you think that the revered historical
figures had the reputational luxury of
not living in a time with the internet
where they couldn't have their legacies
blown with bizarre interviews or bad
tweets or a TMZ video or a leaked nude
or text or something would we view many
of these people differently possibly
with less reverence if they were alive
now [ __ ] great question yes 100
uh your
uh mutants of the world would be seen
through this much more broad lens right
an entire world view of this entire
person all of his Fireballs the fact
that he was like
just a horrible person by by the sound
of things that also happen to be genius
at the moment separating the art and the
artists are almost impossible because
people are their opinions they are their
takes online and no one that is famous
and good at one thing doesn't decide to
have takes
it would be an entirely different world
if that happened
Carl Campbell what is something that you
are still proving to yourself even at
this stage of your podcasting career
[ __ ] that's a good question as well
um
still the worthy of love thing I think
uh that
even more than that actually that
there's been a big change over the last
12 months of how
much attention and how many
opportunities I've been getting like the
number of things that have come in
sponsor opportunities
um paths that I could go down ways that
I could be distracted have been
um
like insane but my
lack of confidence or like vestigial
lack of confidence
still lingers there so the Imposter
syndrome is still pretty real but that's
starting to get to drop away which is
nice but proving to myself that like I'm
worthy of Love without having to offer
people something in return and also that
I deserve to be here I deserve to have
the successes that the show's got is
probably it as well
lj22 status is a frequent topic of
discussion on Modern wisdom when
covering topics such as intra and
intersexual competition cancel culture
group dynamics in the dating Market if
you were to give the power to convey a
higher status to a particular
characteristic or trait that you feel is
currently undervalued in society what
would you choose for the trait you
select who do you think best
demonstrates The Virtue whilst not
receiving sufficient recognition for
doing so mothers 100 it would be mothers
I think that the lack of pedestalization
of motherhood
makes it not
very un
uh aspirational very
um unmotivating to want to be that and
just pick any any stay-at-home mum that
decides to work hard manage a household
which is not a small task uh make sure
that the kids and everything else is
oiled nicely that would be
uh if we got to the end of 2030 and that
was starting to become more pedestalized
again that would I would consider that a
win
Claire McLeod smashing it 600k my
question please is there anything in
your end of your review that surprised
you and if yes why thank you I haven't
done my end of your review yet so
I don't know however if you want to do
your own end of your review you can go
to chriswillex.com review you can see
the process that I will be doing when I
finish mine
um
I would guess that it will be one of the
things I would be surprised by uh will
be the impact of having friends that
believe in you uh and that support you
and understand what you're doing like
that's a a power that is very very
difficult to
um realize just how good it is
Steven
Mojo any chance you're going to have
Michael malison yes for his new book the
white pill which you I think you can get
it white the white pill book or white
pillbook.com
and I'm going to be speaking to him
right now today
while this goes out and it should be
live this Thursday
uh and then David Goggins goes live on
Monday so it's a good very good week
that we've got anyway I'm gonna leave it
there I love you all thank you 600k is
wild one mil maybe by the end of 2023
that'd be great
um keep sharing the episodes the people
that do you are my favorite humans it
makes a massive massive difference also
don't forget if you want to get access
to all of the episodes 10 hours before
they go live on YouTube you can
subscribe on Spotify to Modern wisdom or
apple podcast to Modern wisdom they get
uploaded 10 hours earlier on there for
now that's it see you at 700k
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]